world is watching minneapolis this
morning as we await a verdict in the
trial of derrick shovin over the death
of george floyd
less than one year ago chauvin as you
know
is charged with second degree murder
third degree murder and second degree
manslaughter
he faces a maximum of 40 years in prison
if he's convicted
the city which has been rocked by months
of protest is today
transformed by thousands of national
guard troops last night there was a
large scale and we should point out very
peaceful demonstration
as the jury deliberates jamie yukas has
been covering this trial from the very
beginning
and she joins us now jamie number one
i'm so glad to see you in person i'm
going to start with that
and i think it's far too early to start
reading the tea leaves but everybody's
already asking how long do you think
it's going to take no one could possibly
i think that's part of the anxiety right
because we just don't know
so there's no way of knowing the verdict
could come at any time even today
yesterday after almost a full day of
closing arguments
the jury deliberated for more than four
hours before stopping for the night
prosecutors replayed the video of george
floyd's final moments for the jury
and we want to remind you it's very
disturbing
what the defendant did here was a
straight up
felony assault and he did it on purpose
in their final plea to jurors
prosecutors explained why former
minneapolis police officer
derek shovin should be found guilty of
murdering george floyd
the defendant abandoned his values
abandoned the training
the prosecution took jurors through
video of chauvin kneeling on floyd's
neck
and told them to quote believe your eyes
it's what you felt in your gut
it's what you now know in your heart
this wasn't policing
this was murder prosecutors also pointed
to the police officers who testified
chauvin used unreasonable force he
didn't follow
training he did not perform cpr he knew
better
he just didn't do better when it was the
defense's turn
derek chovin removed his mask and looked
directly at his attorney eric nelson
who asked jurors to consider what
happened in the minutes before
the deadly encounter a reasonable police
officer
would in fact take into consideration
the previous
16 minutes and 59 seconds
their experience with the subject
the struggle that they had the defense
also reiterated their theory
floyd died of a heart attack or drug
overdose
were there other contributing factors
that were not the natural result of mr
chauvin's acts
the drug ingestion the bad heart
the diseased heart the hypertension
but the prosecution countered during
their rebuttal i'll show it to you you
were told
that mr floyd died because his heart was
too big
and the truth of the matter is that the
reason george floyd
is dead is because mr sheldon's heart
was too small
the state has failed to prove its case
beyond a reasonable doubt
and therefore mr showrun should be found
not guilty of all counts
the 12 jurors are very diverse half are
black americans and people of color
which is unusual in this mostly white
hennepin county
the jury is also on the younger side
most scale are younger than the age of
50.
yeah i'm very fascinated by your city
jamie as i said i've never been here
before but number one it's beautiful
number two it's so jarring because most
of it is boarded up but you also see
magnificent construction that's going on
to add to the beauty of the place
what has this been like for you covering
this because you know this city very
very well
i think it's been really hard you know
to hear the anxiety i have family who
lives here not far from where this
occurred there's been a lot of tension i
also think growing up here people talk
about minnesota nice
i think a lot of people questioning have
we really been that nice
what conversations need to happen where
can change occur
the city is is known for its beauty for
being very clean
i think this is a very dirty situation
and people really having
an opportunity to talk about things and
get to know their neighbors a little bit
more i think
people have looked at this it's been
such a segregated city for so long
really reaching across and many
different religious leaders have been
talking about this how do we bring
people together from different parts of
the city
to talk about change and moving forward
after this case is resolved
i was talking to people yesterday on the
streets i just wondered out a little bit
security was very nervous about me
walking around
but people were saying to me that
minneapolis is known for its laid-back
demeanor carefree and happy and now it
seems a very sad place but they know
that there's a lot at stake
but the people who live here really love
this city we do i mean it's
it's cold today right it's april we had
snow flurries
but it's one of those things i think
when you grow up here you have the sense
that i can get through anything
and so this is just another time that
the city is going to have to get through
all right jamie and we will be here good
to see you